en verdad los precios mundiales de
productos alimentarios beneficios ya
sufrían un incremento ahí desde
2020 221
debido a incremento de precios de los
fertilizantes
progresivamente pero también ha
ocasionado el incremento de peso de gas
y de petróleo que su opción en ocasiones
puede cubrir que afectan el costo de
transporte ahora en este mes de marzo
así ya sentimos el efecto de la guerra
porque está de ucrania y rusia son
responsable presenta casi el 30 por
ciento de las exportaciones mundiales de
trigo y alrededor de 80 presente las
exportaciones mundiales de girasol que
afecta del 13 o de los aceite como mucho
más entonces todos estos factores juntos
y ocasionales de este récord de los
precios de los índices de los precios de
alimentos que se se mensura desde 1990 o
sea este precio de este mes el
incremento de 33 por ciento también en
relación a marzo del año pasado cuáles
son las regiones más afectadas y qué
pasa en américa latina en particular
a todo el mundo de una manera es
afectado no pero principalmente norte de
áfrica y países de áfrica que depende
muchísimo de las exportaciones de
cereales y aceites de dulce y ucrania
son son muy fuertemente afectados en la
región de la región toda nuestra región
de américa latina y el caribe es
dependiente de importaciones de
fertilizantes porque además de exportar
los cereales también son regiones que
exportan en los brazos de los países que
exportó mucho los fertilizantes y ahí
está nuestro riesgo entonces no hay país
que no será afectado por el tema no
solamente de las
importaciones que dependen de él
dependemos de estos países pero también
de los mismos hay alguna forma de
contrarrestar esta tendencia está alza
en los precios
si hay que estar preparado para buscar
esta diversificación de nuestros socios
comerciales de los países
naturalmente hay países que van a tener
que suplir esta necesidad de demanda por
los cereales y por aceites pero también
de fertilizantes de muy importante no
generar
instrucciones o distorsiones en el
comercio
porque esto puede empeorar más aún el
tema de la volatilidad del incremento de
precios o sea mantener el comercio
abierto no no dejes de
restringir y al mismo tiempo
ampliar toda la transparencia y diálogo
sobre políticas entre países para
minimizar estas interrupciones y no
garantizar el flujo de transporte que es
fundamental en este momento
proteger a los agricultores que dependen
de los insumos para la producción
protegiendo a las poblaciones más
vulnerables
van a tener un impacto en sus
condiciones de compra de alimentos de
los alimentos y van a incrementar ya
están incrementando y si hay que
fortalecer los sistemas de protección
social a las poblaciones donde antes